[Music]
and the epic battle everyone has been
waiting for
there we go good start
okay that was accidental if anything
right now receives a pretty high Dion
plays so I'm kind of going for neither
of you right now thank you
oh that's right
well that was uh yeah I told you it's
the best in America pretty awesome all
right I got you corner now you're in
trouble
there is a lot of neon green blood I
won't if I could move Oh
bringing the stick out I had to do
something that's very in character the
predator would use any weapon available
you generally like to use one on him
yeah but he will use anything oh he will
he doesn't look down on primitive
technology like a spiked baseball bat so
far that was a that was a blow-up and I
also really like aliens uppercut
yeah it's just like the jumping the
jumping headbutt yeah it's pretty fast
oh wow right
wake up x-ray that's some tech that you
guys can use just so you know that's
great it's free that's free wake up
x-ray wake up x-ray big battle going on
here a lot of Dreams oh you almost
completed it - thanks
almost it's kind of my middle name you
start counting the one that you like to
use yeah I like to cotton
[Music]
so we're naturally going to do two out
of three hours
you